so who is it is it joe biden well i'm
not so sure is joe biden really the one
calling the shots you may have seen this
it happened on friday
joe biden tried to walk up a flight of
stairs and
he stumbled more than stumbled he fell
right down three times we see him
walking up the stairs to air force one
mary stumbles there he falls again there
he just goes all the way down
rubs off his leg now he grabs onto both
railings makes it into the airplane
finally
very sad i don't want to make fun of an
elderly man for
falling down the stairs the staffers
tried to blame this on the wind if you
look at national weather service the
wind in that area it was
a light breeze was not heavy wind
this is just more affirmation
that joe biden is not the man he once
was
and fair enough if we you have relatives
who are 78 years old
do you think that they can run up and
down stairs all sprightly while they're
leading the free world
in some cases look there's some people
who can do it but generally speaking no
probably not so is he really calling the
shots
i also don't want to hear that bringing
up joe biden's fall
is cheap i don't want to hear that it's
unseemly or that it's irrelevant
give me a break after what we heard from
donald trump i don't want to hear about
it trump of course
had some things to say about biden's
fall
i watched as joe biden went up the
stairs today
i said i didn't lose to him
almost 75 million votes and probably a
lot more than that
so there it is a classic trombone yeah i
watched him walk up the stairs
i did not lose to that guy okay i
there's no way that i
it can't have happened it's not possible
okay and the people laugh
and i'm sure he's going to be you know
they're going to increase his gulag
sentence now by 30 years for
spreading the misinformation of telling
a funny joke that rings true to a lot of
people because
biden's obviously not all with it but i
don't want to hear it
for to me that i shouldn't bring up
joe biden's stumbling and i don't want
to hear people say that donald trump
shouldn't have brought up
joe biden's stumbling because joe biden
did it himself
look at how he steps and look how i
stepped watch how i
run up ramps and he stumbles down ramps
okay
come on it's a legitimate question to
ask legitimate question to ask of both
of us
thank god my health is good but i'm a
great
i'm a great respecter of fate i realize
anything can happen to anybody at any
age any time
but i promise you i would not be running
unless i was in very good health i work
out every morning
and i am in relatively good shape as my
mother would say knock on wood
it's a legitimate question look how i
run up steps look how he
slides down ramps he's talking about how
at a west point game there was a
slippery
ramp no steps ramp so trump walked a
little bit more slowly than he usually
does
look at our run-up steps well we did joe
we are looking at that and joe biden
made an issue out of this
and the left made a big issue out of
this at the time and this feeds into
something that we all know you might
hate donald trump
but i don't think anybody thought that
donald trump was
low energy in decline i mean this is a
guy who was working 24 hours a day
always extremely high energy dancing
around at his rallies
always got the vicious clever you know
jibe
at one of his opponents joe biden i
don't think we've been thinking that and
this raises now even more questions
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
[Music]